Pacific Rim uprising is directed by
Steven s tonight and stars John boyega
as Jack Pentecost son of stacker
Pentecost played by Idris Elba in del
Toro's first film and this time around
the rebellious but courageous Jack leads
a group of Jaeger pilots into battle
against a new onslaught of kaiju del
Toro's previous film was a bit of an
empty human experience but as a vehicle
for delivering exciting mech on monster
mayhem it was fun one of the better
parts of that film was Idris Elba's
performance so it makes sense that
they'd focus on his kid for the next
installment tonight is a filmmaker who
comes from a mostly television
background having worked on shows like
Buffy the Vampire Slayer Angel daredevil
most recently and here his considerable
talent feels jilted by an aggressively
commercial experience uprising takes the
Pacific Rim story and turns it into a
brand a mechanism for Yeager and kaiju
destruction and little else while the
human characters felt weak the previous
go around here the attempts to flesh
them out feel stunningly calculated
almost as if the character building
scenes came complete with a heading
indicating as much as usual John boyega
is a likeable and charismatic presence
he has a lot of range but the comedic
writing in particular for his character
is rather embarrassing he will often
reflect on how sexy and handsome he
thinks he is talking about his perfect
facial structure this happens more than
once and it's always played for comedy
and it's even more awkward because he
often says these things to a 15 year old
girl which is just weird to me he will
often talk about how handsome and sexy
he thinks Scott Eastwood's character is
- and it's always played for comedy and
it never works and it got very
cringe-worthy that 15 year old girl is
played by Kayleigh spane
who I thought was one of the brightest
spots of the film she was charming even
when she was supposed to be annoying boy
Yaga and I'm excited to see what else
she does she has a bright future ahead
of her her performance in the film I
would say is the most respectable out of
the leads her and John boyega but what
they do with Charlie days character here
gonna go have to see the movie because
it was unintentionally hilarious I'm
pretty sure everyone in my row was often
laughing when you're not supposed to be
laughing like you you see Charlie day
and you think okay comedian comedy it's
always sunny it's gonna be there's some
funny stuff here right yeah there's some
parts that are supposed to make you
laugh but eventually the film does some
other things with his character and
you're not supposed to be laughing but
you are because it's just that
embarrassing the first half of the movie
has brief scuffles between good Yeager's
and bad but for the most part it's a lot
of buildup once the real plot rears its
head the remaining half is almost
entirely action while this may be a
relief for some there's only so many
times I can see a mech throw a monster
into a building before it starts to get
surprisingly boring there's an evil
scheme a vial of kaiju blood and
attempts to threaten the population of
earth but in the end it just comes down
to two giant things punching each other
a lot there's even a scene where one of
the jaegers uses a weapon that rises a
bunch of cars into the air and then
forms them into a ball and then he uses
that ball of cars to punch another
Jaeger
with those cars and there's never an
attempt to verify whether or not there
are no civilians in these cars or
whether or not there are any civilians
even remotely near this parking deck and
all these cars that just gets ripped off
the street and then turned into a weapon
there's so many moments like that in the
film that ask you to just not care and
go with it
apparently tonight is a big fan of
Mobile Suit Gundam which is made clear
by one specific moment in the film but
with uprising the homages feel like
Americanization and less like what makes
Gundam special Gundam isn't just about
mechs and space battles and explosions
the major theme of every series in the
franchise is the horror and pain of war
the devastation and senselessness of it
the mech battles are just the icing on
the cake uprising understands how to
present a watchable and entertaining
action sequence but there's nothing
under the surface it's all icing for
some that might be all
are looking for in that case you'll
probably be entertained by this movie
but for anyone else this just feels like
an aggressively corporate movie trying
to be a new brand the next Transformers
it's complete with a stinger at the end
as well setting up a sequel so it really
does have everything a studio could
possibly want I'm gonna give Pacific Rim
Uprising a c-minus if you just want to
see monsters and mechs fighting with
explosions and battles and a lot of
really cool special effects then you've
probably already decided that you're
going to like this movie just go see it
and you'll have fun but if you want to
even remotely care about anything going
on on the screen and watch a film that
has some artistry to it that actually
has a little bit of depth under the
surface this probably isn't going to be
your film just like it wasn't for me
guys thank you so much as always for
watching as always if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]